hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled the american response to kuvid19
what went right what went wrong the
webinar is part of the coronavirus
virtual event series and i'm susie
valdez of labyrinths and i'll be our
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the
top right corner of your presentation
window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
i now present today's speaker dr ashish
a dean from brown university school of
public health
for a complete biography on our speakers
please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
welcome dr jaw you may now begin your
presentation
and thank you so much for having me here
what i'm going to do is i am not going
to be using slides
instead i'm going to speak for about 30
35 minutes
about the state of the pandemic and i'm
going to begin by giving
a bit of a global overview of where
things are
and then i'm going to really talk about
the american response and talk about
what has gone right and there are some
things that have gone right
what has gone wrong and unfortunately
there are lots of things that have gone
wrong
and and then try to really wrap up by
thinking about what does this all mean
for the future
both the future of this pandemic but
also the future
of new pandemics that all of us will
experience
in the years and decades to come so
let's start off by talking about this
pandemic the kovit 19 pandemic
and the state of that pandemic we are
nine
months into what i have been saying and
thinking of
as an 18-month pandemic so let me
explain why i think of this as an
18-month pandemic
and why i think we're approaching the
halfway mark
there are lots of and i'll go through
timelines in a second there are lots of
ways of marking time on this pandemic
but if we
sort of begin with the assumption that
the pandemic began around the first of
this year around january 1st
and when we think about the future the
pandemic won't be over
anytime soon but it will start getting
meaningfully better i believe by about
july 1
of next year so around uh nine months
from now
so that's an 18-month time period
january 1 2020
to july 1 2021 and in that 18-month time
period we're about halfway there
so that's sort of the first key point to
understand is we're not nearly done with
this pandemic
uh and it's not right around the corner
uh we
have a long don't have about as many
days ahead of us as we do behind us
i do want to just put one caveat and
i'll get more into this when we get
into talking about the future is that
life won't magically be
back to normal on july 1 next year but i
do believe that in the united states and
in many other places
it'll be meaningfully better by then so
let's talk a little bit about the
evolution of this pandemic and how it's
gone
globally and then let's shift to talking
about the united states
so the pandemic began in china in wuhan
china
uh it was a natural jump from
probably a bat uh to humans
so you'll hear random stories about it
was developed in a lab it was not
developed in a lab
it's a natural occurring virus that made
a species jump as a lot of this
happens and we don't know when
and my best guess is that it started
circulating in wuhan probably sometime
in october
and probably october november december
were months
of people getting infected and during
those three months october through
december
the virus likely spread to other parts
of china and
i would argue that probably by december
the virus had left
china and had started getting to other
places in the world
at the end of december of the of last
year december 31st in fact the last day
of 2019
the world health organization informed
was informed by china
of this outbreak by mid-january just a
couple weeks later we had identified the
virus we had sequenced it
and i think there was already pretty
good evidence available spread of this
virus
virus by mid-january so if we think of
this virus and where it has really
wreaked
havoc october through december
into much of january in china uh
place that was really where the
epicenter of this pandemic was
i would argue that by february we
started seeing the epicenter shift
to italy and iran and several other
countries
and by march into april it was
much more across western europe
certainly the united states
and then over the months that followed
brazil
russia and currently here we are
in september and if you ask me what is
the epicenter
of the pandemic right now i would say
three places
the united states continues to be an
epicenter generating
uh you know 40 plus thousand cases a day
and a thousand deaths a day brazil
continues to be an epicenter
and then india has really come on
generating
almost a hundred thousand cases a day
and still rising so i think that in the
weeks and months to come you're going to
continue to hear a lot
about how bad things are in india and
how much worse they're going to get over
time
one country that has not had large
numbers
but i find their current estimates to be
probably
to be underestimated and unbelievable
are is russia
so russian numbers look pretty good now
but i think there's lots of indirect
evidence that there's a lot of under
counting happening in russia
so if you really want to think about the
epicenters you can include russia in
that as well but the main countries are
us brazil
india and maybe russia
when we look across the globe because of
course this is a global pandemic and
pretty much every
country in the world has been affected
so when we look
across the world we see wide variations
in how the pandemic has been managed
there are some countries that have done
an
awesome job some countries that have
done kind of a mediocre job and some
countries
that have done an awful job so let's
list some countries
south so countries that have done an
awesome job south korea
new zealand germany there's a bunch of
others
but they have done a very very good job
australia i would put in there european
countries i would put it there
vietnam several countries in africa
really superb job
managing the pandemic there are
countries that have been kind of
okay not terrible but not great in that
in those categories i would put uk and
spain
and sweden and and many other places
and then when i think of the countries
that are truly low performers that have
done an abysmal job of managing
this pandemic i've already mentioned
them brazil
uh russia india increasingly
they did a good job in the beginning and
then the u.s
unfortunately our nation belongs in that
bottom category of countries that have
done a pretty bad job
and i want to get into now kind of
thinking about why the us has done such
a bad job
but let me make one more key point
before i switch to just talking about
the united states
whenever you think of a disease outbreak
whenever you think of a pandemic or any
large disease outbreak
there are two main strategies that exist
to managing a disease outbreak there are
what we call public health measures
and then what we call the biomedical
measures so let me explain both of them
public health measures are things
like wearing mass social distancing
testing and tracing those are classic
public health strategies then biomedical
measures are primarily
therapies making the disease less deadly
and vaccines
again a biomedical intervention to
prevent the infection
when you across the world at the
countries that have done a great job
i i mentioned three for instance new
zealand uh
south korea and germany did they all do
the same thing they didn't
south korea had a fabulous testing and
tracing infrastructure
and that's been their major strategy
japan another country that's done well
has really focused on universal mass
work new zealand has had very very
rigorous lockdowns and germany has done
a bit of all three of those things and
all of them pretty
well and so what you see is that there
isn't one formula for how to control
this virus
in fact it varies from nation to nation
then when we come to the united states
and america doing
and why is america doing so badly i
would argue the primary reason the
united states has done so poorly
is because we have largely not deployed
those public health measures
particularly effectively and that's why
as a nation we have more than six
million cases
two hundred thousand americans dead uh
number one in the world on both of those
counts
all right so i argued that america has
done very poorly because we didn't
deploy public
health measures and by all the metrics
we are number one in the world
in terms of number of cases a number of
deaths now i'm actually going to make a
slightly more nuanced argument
which is when you look at america you
don't see one pattern
you see two different paths
so one of the major features of this
pandemic and the response to it
is that the u.s federal government
largely decided
that they were not going to take a
leadership role and they were going to
leave it up to states
to figure out how to fight a global
pandemic and what that
has meant is that some states have
actually done a
pretty good job and other states have
done an abysmal job
some states look like western europe in
terms of their numbers
and their patterns and some states look
more like brazil
in terms of their cases and their
patterns and i'm going to list a few of
them
obviously i'm not going to go through
all 50 states and list which one belongs
in what which category
but when you look at a lot of the states
in the northeast and in the midwest
they actually look a lot like western
europe hit hard early
lock down effectively have opened up
very slowly
and have the virus under reasonably good
control so what am i thinking of
i'm thinking about new york and
massachusetts and rhode island and
connecticut
and maine and new hampshire and vermont
but also if you shift towards the middle
midwest of the country michigan ohio
there are a bunch of states that have
done a reasonably good job
after getting hit very very hard up
front then you have a series of states
uh that didn't get his heart in the
beginning
but have really not taken the virus
seriously certainly had not through
august so in the last month or so things
have changed a little bit
and i'll come back to that but i'm
thinking about states
like texas and florida and arizona and
large parts of the country missouri
kansas the dakotas
they still continue to have quite
substantial disease a burden
or they did certainly through the summer
arizona has gotten much much better now
but again back to that but there are a
set of states that really have not taken
the virus as seriously as needs to be
and they continue to struggle so let's
now shift to
one of the key points that i want to
cover in mock which is why
has the american response been so poor
and i've already
up to one key part of it which is a lack
of a clear
federal response a decision was made
in the white house that the pandemic was
going to be largely left
up to states and we'd let states figure
out
how to solve this problem the problem
with that strategy
is it's a global pandemic and you can't
have
every state fighting the pandemic on its
own
it's too complicated there are too many
issues and i'll detail some of them
that really require federal resources
and coordination
and without them states have been
largely struggling and even the best
performing states
have not been as good as they would have
been had there been a strong federal
response
so let's get into a bit of the what what
was missing
so if we look at the timeline and again
if we begin with january as a start of
this pandemic
by mid-january it was certainly clear
that this was going to be a global
pandemic
uh on june june sorry january 22nd
and over the next two months much of
january and
all of february the nation was blind
to the fact that the virus was spreading
across large parts of the country
the virus was spreading uh quite
unchecked across
the state of new york and new jersey in
massachusetts
uh in parts of the the west in
washington state and parts of the middle
west
what you had was spreading of the virus
without any idea that it was going on
largely because we had no testing
infrastructure we had not
figured out how to do a basic simple
test to figure out whether you have this
virus or not
for a country with our wealth and our
expertise it's
crazy we basically wasted months
why did that happen it was largely lack
of federal interest and leadership there
were problems at the cdc
there were problems at the fda we could
blame lots of individual people but at
the end of the day
the white house did not take this issue
seriously uh
in fact they spent much of that time
downplaying it saying the virus would go
away it was nothing worse than the flu
and all of that meant that we got into
march
and had little to no testing
infrastructure and by
mid to late part of march to realize oh
my god
this virus is in lots of places lots of
people are infected
things are really starting to get bad
and
uh and we had little to no testing
capacity to figure out
who's infected and who's not and you're
gonna hear a lot of misinformation about
testing so let me just make the point of
why it's so central
if you can't figure out who's infected
and who's not you don't know who to
separate from where
and you can't manage this disease so
testing isn't
everything but it is fundamental without
it you can't do much in the way of
disease control
there was little to no federal effort on
ppe on protecting doctors and nurses
with personal protective equipment there
was a little bit of effort
but we saw through much of march april
and may doctors and nurses
having to go into battle basically
having to go
fight coronavirus and take care of very
sick patients without adequate
protection that unfortunately led to
many doctors and nurses getting sick
and unfortunately many of them dying and
then
last but certainly not least was you saw
very little in the way
of guidance from the federal government
on the shutdown
how to do it uh where shut down what
parts of the economy can remain open
and that i think was another failure of
federal leadership is we just didn't
have the kind of guidance that we needed
at the state level
so that was one major issue lack of
coordination
uh and out of the federal government a
second
key problem that has led to the american
poor american response
is a massive misinformation campaign
uh you may think it's just your uncle uh
uncle bob
uh you know posting some bad information
on facebook
it goes well beyond that facebook really
has become the platform
by which much of the of the
misinformation campaign has spread in
our country
and it's been concerted it's been well
coordinated
and you all know the misinformation the
oh
only 80 year olds die of this disease
it's fine if it's young people
kids never get sick we now know that the
president actually knew that none of
that was true
in his tapes with bob woodward has been
clear he knew that it was a deadly
disease he knew that young people could
get sick
um so this massive misinformation
campaign has been run
by a variety of groups has sown
real discord in our country we have
large numbers of people who believe uh
basically falsehoods uh lies about the
virus about things that are not
true so there's plenty of that we don't
know and there's plenty of areas of
disagreement
honest disagreement but there is also
areas we just have very good information
and yet misinformation continues to
spread and that misinformation
would be bad enough unto itself but then
we
political leaders often spread that
misinformation
validate that misinformation and that
has made it much much
harder and that has led to what i think
is like the third pillar of the real
challenge the american response
and that is politicization of the
scientific process
so the mean scientific agencies in
charge of the u.s response should be the
cdc and the fda cc is our public health
agency responding to this pandemic
and fda as our biomedical agency
so remember i said there were two arms
of the response public health
biomedical cdc does public health fda
does biomedical
both of them have been deeply
politicized we have seen their
scientists recommendations overwritten
we have seen them coming out with
statements and information that we all
know to be frankly just incorrect
and it's been very very distressing it's
been distressing because we've never
seen this kind of politicization
under no previous democratic or
republican governor have we seen
the cdc and fda behave that they the way
that they have
in the last few months and that has
really i think
hampered our national response and made
it much much harder for people
to know what is true what is not and how
we're going to deal with it
okay so um i want to now just bring us
up to speed on how the last few months
have gone
uh because then i can we can take stock
of where we are and look to the future
about where things are going
so if what i laid out in terms of
timeline of the united states that
january and february
were months where we flew blind march
through
may was the shutdown period where we had
lots of deaths
uh and slowly began to ramp up testing
june and july i think of as our lost
months
these were the months we were supposed
to prepare for the fall june july and
august
many of us wrote back in spring that the
fall was going to be really hard
and we needed to use this summer to get
ready for the fall
and we instead of getting ready
basically
wasted that time and unfortunately we
did worse than waste that time we
sowed a lot of misinformation so what
happened during june and july as you all
know
is we saw large spikes in cases we saw
some spikes in in california
huge spikes in arizona texas florida
south carolina
i'm not gonna list all the states uh but
in many many places across the u.s
and unfortunately what you had was
a policy out of the white house and
others
denying that anything bad was happening
so instead of focusing on getting the
country ready for the fall
in fact we fell behind during these
months saw
spikes in cases eventually leading to
large increases in deaths
and yet you had things like the vice
president pending an op-ed in the wall
street journal
i think one of the most shameful moments
of our entire pandemic
when everybody knew things were getting
much worse he wrote a piece basically
saying don't worry
everything is under control there's no
second wave this is all just because of
increased testing
we all knew that wasn't the case we all
knew that these were going to lead to a
lot more people getting hospitalized and
dying
as obviously happened as we went into
the rest of june and july
so um finally i would say by the end of
july
realization that we couldn't just bluff
our way through this virus and this
pandemic
and you did see smart policy responses
in arizona in texas in florida
in the later part of july that led to
what has been the cooling of those cases
in august
so as we entered and have now come out
of labor day let's take a stock of where
we are as a country
where things are going so as we take a
look i would say there's some
pieces of clearly good news so let's
talk about the good news first and then
we'll talk about the challenges
and how we're going to overcome them so
good news uh first
is we have gotten much better at taking
care of this disease uh
our ability to take care of cobit in the
hospital has gotten much much better
one just because doctors and nurses have
gotten better second is we have
therapies
we have two therapies one certainly is a
strong
the other one a bit less clear so the
two therapies that we have that we
didn't in march
are remind severe uh that's a drug that
was approved relatively early we think
it's pretty beneficial if you give it
early and then dexamethasone
and that really does look like it's
really beneficial especially for people
who have advanced disease
in terms of lowering mortality and
lowering how much sicker they
are we we now know and have probably
known since april
that masks work really well that if
there is universal masking if most
people are wearing mass
you really dramatically slow down
infections so that is good news we
didn't have that knowledge in february
or early march we do now third
uh is we know where the virus tends to
spread
this is something we have learned in the
last few months so what we have learned
is a virus likes to spread indoors when
people aren't wearing mats
restaurants bars churches
um lots of contexts where people
churches people can wear masks so that
churches need not be one of those places
but restaurants and bars
one of the reasons they are so dangerous
is it's hard to wear a
mask at a bar because you're drinking
and so
restaurants and indoor dining and bars
have really been one of the major
sources of spread
being outdoors is relatively safe
relatively safe
now you can get it very packed outdoors
without wearing masks
and that would be dangerous but if
you're outside and you're wearing mass
you are relatively pretty safe we've
learned that
i've already talked about therapies and
the other big advancement and i will
talk a little bit more about it
is vaccines we are now probably
somewhere between two and six months
away
uh um from widespread availability of
vaccines two months away probably from
identifying a vaccine and probably six
months maybe a little longer away from
widespread availability of vaccine
so that's all good news that's much
better than where we were in march
let's talk about the challenges in front
of us and then i want to really think
about
how we get through those challenges and
then i will
wrap up by thinking about kind of where
we are as a country and as a globe
so challenges in front of us number one
is indefinitely everybody's getting
tired of this dynamic
you know i often say we are done with
this pandemic
unfortunately the pandemic is not done
with us
so fatigue means people start letting
their guard down
start doing things that are dangerous
and it's really important that we don't
do that
second is the ongoing misinformation and
politicization
uh that wasn't just a problem of march
and april it continued
and the politicization of this virus
is particularly dangerous in the next
six to eight weeks because we're in the
middle of a national campaign
and we are going to see further ramping
up of that politicization
turns out the virus doesn't care about
your political views
the virus really functions on biology
and math
we understand the basic biology and math
of this virus you can be a republican or
a democrat liberal or a conservative
whatever you are you are equally
susceptible to this virus if you don't
understand the rules that the virus
points by
third is we are entering fall and winter
and fall and winter means it's going to
get colder it'll be harder to be outside
and more and more people will spread
spend time indoors
what we know about this virus is that it
likes to spread
when people spend time doors with each
other
so it's favorite way to spread and that
is going to become more commonplace
and so we really have to figure out how
to guard against that and then
last but certainly not least we are
going to have a flu season coming
and the flu season we don't know how
severe it will be
the flu season always taxes our
hospitals
fills them up we've really got to be
careful this fall and winter now
i'm pretty hopeful that we'll end up
having a mild flu season
uh for two reasons one is i hope
everybody gets a vaccine
it's always a good idea to get a flu
vaccine it's a particularly good idea to
get a flu vaccine this year
so that's going to be really critical
but also
beyond that if we're doing social
distancing wearing mass
not having those large indoor gatherings
that should also slow down the flu
season that's what we've seen in the
southern hemisphere
that they're just coming out of their
winter and they've had a milder flu
season because of these
and i'm hoping that happens to us as
well so how do we
how do we get through the next six
months while the vaccine development
moves along
basically it's really about doing the
things
that we know work right so maintaining
social distancing i don't think we need
to go back into lockdowns i sure hope
not
uh but avoiding those large indoor
gatherings that's really going to be
important
wear a mask i wear a mask every time i
leave my house or every time i leave
my office if i'm uh if i'm any chance
i'm going to be around other people i
just wear a mask
it's not that hard it's perfectly safe
and in fact more than safe it's really
healthy for you to be wearing one
because you protect other people
and there is now more and more evidence
that you also protect yourself
let's for more therapies i am actually
pretty optimistic
we may get one or two more treatments
that end up being really useful
uh we will see over the next weeks and
months what that looks like
the more therapies we get that means
that the disease will become less and
less deadly which will be great
and then let's really hope for that
vaccine
so let's talk a bit about the vaccine
and then i will um
soon after that wrap up and think about
the future so the vaccine
production is cooking along so one of
the things that people worry about is
is this going too fast a typical vaccine
can take up to
a decade to develop and here we are nine
months into a pandemic and it feels like
we're
getting pretty close we are getting
pretty close
there's a couple of reasons why we've
made so much progress first we didn't
start from scratch
we actually started uh having a lot of
knowledge
about this kind of coronavirus because
it's similar
not the same but similar to the sars
virus that caused the 2003 sars outbreak
and at that time we had done a lot of
great research on trying to develop a
vaccine against that virus
ultimately we never end up developing
that vaccine but we had a bunch of the
information bunch of the
um science worked out and therefore when
this
virus came into being we were able to
take that knowledge
and turn it into a very rapid
development of a vaccine against this
virus
that's been hugely helpful second
we've had unprecedented coordination and
cooperation
within the scientific community people
often talk about american vaccine or
russian vaccine or german vaccine
there's no american vaccine it's a
scientific vaccine
built by collaborators around the world
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine is
developed by researchers at oxford
using science that has been developed
across the world
and it's these things are all global
it's a scientific community together and
doing extraordinary work
and so we've got to get away from
thinking about things like the american
or the
or the german vaccine there is only
global scientific vaccines
and third we've just moved very very
quickly to try to test these vaccines
out
and my hope is that we're going to have
identified a vaccine to be safe and
effective sometime later in the fall
or winter november december
then we have to ramp up production we've
got to get
uh vaccines out to hundreds of millions
of americans
and so within the united states i expect
that we will have
widespread availability of a vaccine
probably in the kind of april through
june range
some people will start getting
vaccinated maybe even by the end of this
year
probably healthcare workers first
responders more high-risk groups by
january february
but it'll really be into march april may
maybe later
that we have large numbers of americans
getting vaccinated
and that's why i picked end of june
early july as kind of
a benchmark time that says by that time
enough people have been vaccinated that
things will really look better
this is of course all contingent on
having a vaccine that works
and it's safe so none of us know whether
that's going to happen but i am
optimistic that that is going to happen
okay let me wrap up two three minutes
here on the future
one important issue for people to
understand
is that this is because this is not an
american outbreak break a
global pandemic the goal is not just to
get americans vaccinated in fact
while america wants to get americans
vaccinated the germans want to get
germans vaccinated and the brits want to
get
the british people vaccinated and
indians need to get vaccinated and
chinese and et cetera et cetera et
cetera
we actually need to vaccinate somewhere
between five and seven
billion people that is an enormous
enormous challenge never done anything
like this
and just making that much vaccine is
going to be very very hard
but beyond making it making sure that we
actually have all the vials and all the
cold chain and all the supply stuff that
is necessary
to take a vaccine developed in a lab and
get it
to a human being so it can be injected
is an
incredible logistical challenge one way
to think about it is taking us
nine months eight months to test do a
test on about 70 80 million americans
testing is much much easier than
building and deploying a vaccine
so i would not underestimate the
complexity
of getting all americans vaccinated and
getting the whole world vaccinated
i think it'll be well into 2022 and
maybe even longer
before much of the world is vaccinated
next
key point is that you keep hearing
politicians say oh the virus will go
away
the virus will not go away it will
probably never
go away it will become endemic in many
many
populations what i mean by that is even
with high levels of vaccinations in many
places not everybody will be vaccinated
not every community will be vaccinated
you'll see little outbreaks here and
there
and they will infect people and people
will get sick and some people will
continue to die now hopefully
as treatments get better and vaccines
get better those numbers get smaller and
smaller
but we will be living with this virus
for a long time it is hard for me to
imagine
that we will completely eliminate this
virus from the human population
we've only been able to do that with
smallpox it's very hard to do
and i don't expect that that's what's
going to happen
let me now talk about beyond this
specific pandemic
how to think about where we are as a
world and where we are going
we are entering an age of pandemics
while this is the biggest pandemic in a
hundred years
we are seeing more and more disease
outbreaks across the world
the number of disease outbreaks the
number of large outbreaks has gone up
substantially over the last 30 years
and i don't think that we're going this
is the last pandemic we're going to see
anytime soon i would not be surprised if
within the next decade
there's another one so let's talk about
why
and then let's talk about what we can do
to manage and prevent those
so the reason why i argue we are
entering an age of pandemics
is that we are seeing large-scale
economic development of much of the
world
china india countries across the african
continent
economic development is a good thing it
lifts people out of poverty it brings
people into
a higher quality of life it does all
sorts of good things
economic development also is often tied
to
and connected to environmental change
and environmental change often means
people are interacting more with animals
that there is
deforestation and of course the biggest
environmental change issue of all
we there is which is climate change
climate change other environmental
changes
means that that we are going to be more
and more exposed to these viruses
it's worth understanding that whenever
you look at new outbreaks of diseases
in human populations they usually come
from animals
mostly they're zoonotic and so that is a
major
issue that why we're going to see more
outbreaks and then last but certainly
not least is globalization
the incredible global travel means that
a disease outbreak in one place
can become a global outbreak very very
quickly just as we saw with this virus
that is the future that is the future
more disease outbreaks
more global disease outbreaks i believe
there's a lot we can do i mean obviously
we've got to address climate change
we're not going to change globalization
but we got to invest
in surveillance systems we've got to
invest in science
and we've got to invest in ways of
countering this information
because misinformation is one of the
biggest culprits
that really slow down our ability as a
nation and as a globe
fight disease outwards we have
an incredibly strong tool to fight these
challenges and that is the human brain
that is the ability
of humans across the world to be able to
creatively solve these problems
but that is only going to work if we
work collectively
and if we let science and evidence guide
us
and that's the work we have to do so let
me wrap up here by saying thank you for
having me uh it has been an enormous
challenge for our country and the world
the u.s has not
been a shining light of how you fight a
pandemic
but we remain a country with incredible
intellectual and financial
resources and we can be the leaders for
how to prevent the next pandemic
and really help the whole world get
through the pen the this and the rest
and future pandemics so thank you again
and i'm happy to stop and take
questions and comments
and thank you dr dob for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located
on the far left of your screen so let's
get started
draw we have quite a few questions
coming in already from our live
audience members what do we do
in the us being in a misinformation
campaign and lacking
federal leadership
what do we do to counter that
i don't generally the question um
what do we do in the u.s the question
yep number two uh
yes so what do we do to counter it i
mean first of all i think
um we we really do have to hold
political leaders who spread
misinformation accountable
we are a democracy as a democracy when
our political leaders act badly
we have to hold them accountable for it
so
political leaders should not be
spreading misinformation one of the key
differences
between us and germany for instance and
one of one of the things that i
point out people point out is germany
also has lots of people spreading this
information
but angela merkel who's the chancellor
of germany
has been really very strong in pushback
against that nonsense
and and making sure that science is
guiding the german policy response
um we need to hold all political leaders
who spread that misinformation
so i really think that's going to be
pretty critical i also think there's a
responsibility
of platforms like facebook i mean
facebook likes to say well it's not our
fault it's not our job people can do
whatever they want
i think that world has changed and being
the
major conduit of misinformation given
that
misinformation is a major reason why so
many americans have died
i do think it's the responsibility of
platforms to take
more uh ownership of the from
misinformation they are spreading
and curtail it and that's going to be
hard for them but they got to do it
so that's also really important
thank you so much there seems to be a
big controversy over whether
children should be going back to school
versus online learning
what is your professional opinion about
that
ah this is this question and i've been i
probably asked something about schools
and kids
about uh i don't know eight ten times a
day uh so let me let me tell you how i
think about it
uh first and foremost there's varied
evidence
that getting kids back to school is very
important
especially younger kids do very badly
with online learning
and in-person learning experience is
critical
second is when you have when you don't
have in-person learning
what you have is a widening of the
digital divide
you know why the achievement gap so when
we
go largely online what will happen is
kids from poor families kids from
communities of color kids who have fewer
advantages
they're gonna fall further behind so
being online
is hugely harmful in that way and then
the last thing about
why being online is a huge problem then
i'll talk about what to do
um the last thing is that what we also
know is that when kids are online
somebody's got to take care of them at
home and guess who gets to take care of
them at home
as much as we might talk about gender
equality in our country
the reality is that it's predominantly
women
and that has a huge negative labor
market effect on women what i mean by
labor market effect is
women are more likely to then quit their
jobs they're more likely to take lower
paying jobs
and it's a huge burden for like families
this
is why we've got to figure out how to
get kids back to school
safely now that's the key word safely
because no one will send kids back in if
it's going to be dangerous for them and
if it's going to be dangerous for
teachers and staff
single biggest factor of whether you can
send kids back to school safely
is how much community transmission is
happening so places like new york city
eastern massachusetts large parts of
california large parts of michigan other
states
community transmission is low enough
that you can't send kids back to school
safely
everybody's got to wear a mask you got
to have some amount of social distancing
and you've got to work on making sure
that school buildings have reasonable
amount of ventilation
and sometimes that just means opening
windows if you can do all of that
in places without high transmission you
actually can
send kids back to safely the problem is
that in places that are with very very
high levels of transmission
sending kids back would be dangerous not
just your kids but obviously you can't
run
we can't run schools without adults and
we got to keep teachers and
staffs as well and so this is not a
teachers versus kids thing we got to
keep everybody safe when we send people
back to school
thank you for that and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
coming in dr john does influenza
affect your immune system to the extent
that it will make you more vulnerable
um make it more vulnerable to the
coronavirus
that's a very good question short
answers we don't know
um we don't know we there aren't any
scientific studies that i'm aware of i
mean
that you know obviously i haven't read
everything but everything i have read
i'm not aware that anybody's looked at
that
in general now this is a general comment
um infections from a virus at least for
a
short period of time a couple of weeks
often make you actually less susceptible
to other viruses
because you get this strong antiviral
response in your body
and it actually makes you less
susceptible at least that has been shown
in some
other viral infections so i don't i
doubt i'm not sure i doubt that if you
got the flu
uh you'd be more susceptible and be for
that short period of time you might be a
little less susceptible
that's not my way of saying go out and
get the flu because that has its own
costs and people get quite sick
but i don't think i've seen any evidence
that getting the flu would make you more
susceptible to covet
thank you for that dr what is the best
lesson
we have learned from this pandemic and
what can we do
to prepare for the next one yeah so the
biggest lesson
is you've got to trust the science the
science isn't always perfect
it's you know science is a
self-correcting self-updating process
science isn't some magical thing it's a
process it's a way of thinking about
problems
and if what we have got done is in
january none of us knew anything about
this
and every month our knowledge has gotten
better and better and better
so if we were talking together in march
there's a lot that i said today that i
wouldn't have been able to tell you
because i didn't know those things
um in march i don't think i really
appreciated maths were useful
um they might have been but i wouldn't
have called it but now we have very good
evidence that they are
so the key here is to listen to
scientists is to listen to the science
and not to listen to politicians and
people who spread misinformation
i have been shocked at the number of
people who have become experts
on coronavirus and you look at their
biography
and like they've spent most of their
lives doing finance
in texas and now they're all of a sudden
like coronavirus immunity experts
and the key here is you got to look at
them with a lot of skepticism right so
you'll see a lot of junk
you got to look up who these people are
what their expertise is
usually most of the people spreading
misinformation
don't really have much expertise they're
picking random facts
out of a whole sea of information
and trying to make a case you didn't
have a motivation behind what they're
trying to do is
they're really thinking about how do
they get their business going how do
they
and that's what's motivating them so
what i would say for the
this pandemic and future ones is listen
to the scientists
and one of the key things is that most
scientists
will express on people don't know
what and that's a key thing if the
person you're talking to
always has all the answers
i probably wouldn't listen to anything
they have to say
listen to people who share with you what
they know and what they don't know
because that's what scientists are
trained to do is to know what they don't
know
and how to how to communicate that
effectively
thank you for that how long will studies
take
to determine whether prior infection
confers
immunity and for how long and this is a
two-part question
there are numerous individuals who
believe they had
stars cov2 in late fall early winter
2019 isn't it possible that there was a
different strain
of multiplication at that time great
question so let's talk about
uh let's talk about the first question
first which is what do we know about
immunity and then let's talk about
what people might have had in the fall
and winter
so there's good news and bad news but
mostly good news on immunity
i see the the data so far in immunity as
being reasonably good so let me explain
what we know
um first of all we have seen some cases
of reinfections
so we have at least a few documented
cases
including the person in hong kong who
was reinfected just
four months after having his
pre-perfection so what that means is it
made a lot of people nervous my god that
means immunity may not last very long
but actually none of us believed that
this is going to be one of those
infections where you get it once and
then you're done
and for life you'll be protected those
are very rare they happen but they're
pretty rare
and we've all believed that this is an
infection where people
can get reinfected the three key
questions in my mind
are how often does reinfection happen is
it occasional
or is it very common second and even
more importantly
when you get re-infected do you have a
milder version
or do you have a more severe version and
then the
third and you get infected can you
spread it to others
here's what we know it looks like people
get reinfected
pretty rarely not zero but pretty
infrequently we haven't seen
large numbers of people getting
reinfected so that's good news
second in most of the cases of
reinfections
the second time around people it's a
milder disease
that's great news that actually is
pretty classic of how immunity works
on the issue of when you get reinfected
can you spread to others we just don't
know
we just don't have enough cases yet so
reinfections
are gonna happen but luckily they look
like they don't happen a lot and
luckily so far we just
they don't look like they're more severe
the second time on the issue of what
people
think they had in the fall and winter
we've had i've heard a lot of this
there's been a lot of efforts to try to
go back and look to see if
sars kovi 2 was circulating and we find
very little evidence um so here's where
what i do think
if you i doubt there was any stars kobe
2
in any meaningful way before december in
the united states
so if you had something that you feel
like could have been coronavirus
my guess is you probably had a bad case
of the flu
second is there were probably some small
number of cases in december
and jan and more in january but they
weren't large in numbers so if you're
like the
one of the few people who had it
possible you can go get an antibody test
and find out
but my general take is most people and
we've seen this from evidence most
people who think they had it
probably didn't have it
thank you so much we have time for a
couple more questions
in contrast to the us
response china seems to have done a
miraculous job
of containing and reportedly eliminating
the threat of the coronavirus in their
country
disregarding the role of chinese
leadership do you think
this is humanly possible yeah so
china has done an interesting job with
this fire so let's talk about china
a little bit and i i am going to just
talk a little bit about their leadership
too but uh
you know so they did ignore the virus
for months and i do think that was a
major wide spread as far as it did and i
think that's a huge
problem um china did bring the virus
under control
they implemented this insanely
aggressive lockdown
basically especially in wuhan but in
other places too
it was essentially a police state you
could not leave your house
without special permission and for only
various specific things and they did it
for a
very long time sure
that works i don't know that first of
all i don't think it's necessary to be
that aggressive
and b i don't think our country and most
people in the world would tolerate that
level
of aggressive police state so china has
shown that it is possible to really
bring this under control
i just don't know that that level of
aggressiveness is necessary
and of course there are huge civil
rights and other types of problems with
it and human rights problems with it
you know if they basically did things
like if you got infected
you couldn't go home and they would put
you in a different place
whether you liked it or not against your
will to recover
i think forcibly removing people from
their homes away from their spouses and
kids is a pretty tough way to do this so
my point is yes china controlled it no
we don't need to do the chinese approach
we could have done a lot of things short
of that and still got response in our
country
thank you so much when we actually have
a vaccine dr jaw
how will it be assured that all
individuals will have
access to it for example those who are
uninsured
and how long will it take for it to be
available to
everyone it's a fabulous question
super duper important and has gotten way
too little attention
um we don't have a clear financial
government about distribution
and and access so it's going to be
really important
that we have broad access to this
vaccine
and that financial barriers are not
there in terms of making people
vaccinated
so i believe what's going to happen is
we are going to we have to set up a
an approach to tiering kind of people
based on
probably basements so again first
responders healthcare workers
should be the first group that gets it
high-risk individuals need to get it a
relatively early on
and then over time everybody else can
get it and that's just going to be based
on availability because we're not going
to have 300 million
uh sets of doses immediately right so
it's going to take a little while to
wrap up so you gotta go by risk
i didn't say you shouldn't we should not
go by income level right so i didn't say
the wealthy people get it first then
middle class people then the poor
that is what i'm worried is going to
happen that there is going to be efforts
to cut lines
there's going to be ways that people are
going to figure out how to and we've got
to really try not to do that because i
think it's going to
create a lot of discord in our country
if
wealthy people who have no risk factors
are getting it before poor people who
have high
substantial risk factors so we gotta
make sure that doesn't happen
and then obviously we cannot have
financial barriers
can't be that you're uninsured or you
are poor
and therefore you can't get a vaccine
that would be that would be morally
awful
but really bad public health policy so
we've got
i want to see a plan from the federal
government of how we're going to avoid
all of those pitfalls
and how we're going to get this
implemented uh the federal government is
working on it we haven't seen that quite
out in all details that i'd like
thank you so much when we actually
have um oh i'm sorry i apologize um
is it possible that the differences in
the responses of various
national leaderships to the pandemic
can you tell greatly the shift in the
global economic leadership
i'm not sure i totally understand the
question but let me try this
one is first of all countries that did a
better job responding to the virus have
had
less economic damage so that's one issue
to think about
second is i do believe
that as we emerge from this pandemic and
we
look back and did well and who did
poorly we are going to
rethink our mental model of who are the
truly sophisticated advanced countries
of the world
and america is not going to come out on
top
this has done more damage to american
reputation than possibly anything we've
done in decades
much of the world looks at us in shock
and disbelief
i talk to leaders across the world and
they
mostly can't believe how badly america
is doing we have done
enormous damage to our reputation that
reputation
is going to have spillover effects on
our economic power
on our political power we are going to
come out a
much much much weaker country
because of our response to this pandemic
so i do think that the
pandemic response will end up
translating into both economic and
political power response
and it will end up shaping the way the
world looks at us
in the years and decades to come
thank you so much dr john again i want
to thank our audience members for these
great questions we have time for one
more question
dr john clearly the federal government
has made
some mistakes we can't turn back time
if you were president right now what
would you do
in regards to mandates and protocols to
reduce the illness and deaths
moving forward yeah yeah so if i
if i was the uh magical tsar of the
coronavirus for our
concrete first of all i'd make sure that
we had universal mass squaring um and
and
whether the federal can do that or you
need to work with states uh we could
work through that but you need to have
everybody wearing masks and you just
need a mandate and then you gotta
enforce that mandate i think that's
critically important second is we've
been dithering around
on getting our testing infrastructure
fixed we still can't do testing in
schools we still can't do testing uh
in prisons and in meatpacking plan so we
gotta get tested fix
i would do that third is i would
communicate effectively with the
american people
that we're not done it's not around the
corner we have a ways to go
and we gotta hunker down get through the
next three to six months
get the vaccine start getting out and
once people start getting vaccinated
life will get better won't go back to
normal
but it will get meaningfully better
communication
fixed testing get people to wear masks
and make sure you have ways of getting
through it as a country
doctor job this has been an outstanding
presentation thank you so much
would you like to provide any final
comments for our audience before we
close
sure let me just take 60 seconds and say
the following this has obviously been an
extraordinarily difficult time for all
of us
as a country as a world but
the bottom line is the destiny of how
these pandemics like this go is in our
hands right it is not
faded we can beat this thing we can
even now with the poor american response
we can turn it around and become one of
the global leaders
if we do what's right and if we follow
the science and as
individuals it mean you may feel
powerless but you're not
the things you can do are fight
misinformation when you see it
speak the truth point to science and
hold political leaders accountable
if we did all of that we would get
through this pandemic better
and we would be much more and much
better prepared for the next one
so thank you again for having me and
enjoy the rest of the events
and thank you again dr job very
inspiring very important
thank you for your time today before we
go i want to thank our audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed
on demand for six months until march
2021
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay safe
stay healthy take care bye